[Music]
when I hear the names TN Tamara the
first thing that comes into my head is
the opening of their show Sister Sister
it had these annoying drawings of these
crying babies and this obnoxious theme
song where they shouts is dead and it
was grouped in with usually some bad
gimmicky family shows so like a fair
amount of people I always kind of
associate them with being gimmicky and
annoying but honestly when you watch the
show it's not that bad the two of them
had good comedic timing and they had a
good supportive cast that was funny as
well the only thing that got annoyingly
old outside of the intro is whenever
they would do anything in unison like
say stuff at the same time or gasp at
the same time or squee at the same time
but I have to be honest as family shows
go especially leaning towards kids
entertainment it was fine twitches is
the exact same thing there's some funny
creative stuff on top of some corny and
gimmicky stuff and at the center of it
are these two actresses who have grown
their comedic timing over the years can
even do the dramatic stuff pretty well
and can surprisingly carry a film apart
from again
when they have to do anything in unison
like say go twitches go twitches it's
our birthdays o light sister sister the
movie focuses on the twins being
separated at Birth only to accidentally
bump into each other years later or was
it an accident this bickering couple who
honestly gets more laughs than they
probably should are kind of like their
guardian angels they watch them over the
years make sure they don't get too much
in trouble but they alter their courses
so that they'll eventually meet in a
particularly enjoyable joke where they
have to keep dropping clues to get one
of them in a department store you see
these guardian angels and the girls
themselves it turns out are magical they
had to be kept apart Alice starwars ala
Harry Potter to protect them from the
darkness and especially horrible fact
that you say only have to look at
throughout the majority of the film
thankfully there's a lot of imagination
in other scenes for example despite the
sisters being very similar they both
seem to have their opposite sides like
one enjoys being up during the day and
the air enjoys being up during the night
one is a writer who writes about this
magical world that it turns out is where
they came from and the other is an
artist who thinks she's drawing
self-portraits but somehow she feels
like it's not her on top of that their
magic only seems to work when they're
close to each other hence why one has a
necklace
the Sun and the other has a necklace of
the moon little touches like this I
guess are obvious but there are also a
lot of fun they show a connection in
both relationship and ability as well as
make for some great visual storytelling
things get even more complicated though
when their mother finds out they're
alive and obvious not bad guy is gonna
help her find them the fight thing is
for as obvious as some of this dialogue
is these actors really tried their
damnedest to pull it off listen to this
incredibly clumsy exposition done almost
perfectly by these two actors who are
really giving their hardest someone has
been protecting them you know they were
killed in the battle that night with
Aaron my husband your brother heroes
they have no doubt but like the girls
their bodies never were found were they
that almost sounded natural even the
villain we look at him and we know he's
the bad guy but look at how charming he
is and how smooth he is you actually
kind of really want to admire him for
how diabolical he can be but I know it's
a Disney Channel movie we're not gonna
get that deep I mean what these two
girls were separated from their parents
and even though they both have step
parents and one even had a step hair and
dyed replaced with another step pair and
now she's gonna meet her actual mother
come on
they're not gonna address any of this
actually they do one of the twins mother
died three months ago and this other
mother has to take over only to discover
another mother is thrown into the mix
the real mother a good chunk of the
emotions you think would follow
something like this actually are
included she doesn't want to meet the
actual mother because she's lost so many
mothers before and even the stepmother
she has now is feeling betrayed because
she's almost dismissing her and the
acting from everyone impressively pulls
it off
it's never too heavy that feels like a
soap opera but it's not really ignored
either it does add a nice sense of drama
and make the story feel a lot bigger
than honestly it probably has any right
to be honey sure it has the lane lines
in roll your eyes moments but there's
not as many as you would think in fact a
good chunk of the scenes are supposed to
get last do legitimately get laughs I
really love this one scene where the
sister is saying she should be more
aware of her surroundings only to look
right past her sister and see a sale at
a mall look at the way that shot that's
legitimately humorous so yeah for an
idea about sister's sister being witches
that battle evil this is much better
than it probably should be it's nothing
great and there's dumb moments but for
the audience it's aimed that there's
just enough comedic timing dramatic
moments and creativity to make it pretty
good if you just ignore the gimmicky
scenes where they have to say stuff at
the same time you might actually find
yourself having a fair amount of fun
[Music]